bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions qui vous vaccine contre tous
les variants du politiquement correct
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de l'or métal
bonjour espère bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous bienvenue dans ces caches
relativement épargné au niveau sanitaire
l'afrique perd lourd tribut économique
et social le président français souhaite
renforcer les investissements pour le
continent alors que selon le fmi
il manque près de 300 milliards de
dollars à l'afrique pour investir
massivement afin de développer ses
infrastructures enrayer la pauvreté ou
encore affronter le changement
climatique emmanuel macron a notamment
évoqué à l'idée de mobiliser les
réserves d'or du fmi pour aider le
continent africain alors comment ce
mécanisme pourrait-il se mettre en place
est ce une bonne idée ce sont les
questions qui vont nous occuper dans
cette émission
et pour cela on rejoindra en deuxième
partie jean françois faure fondateur
d'eau coffre points comme mais d'abord
on va revenir sur ce qu'il s'est dit
lors du sommet de la mi mai consacrée à
l'afrique à l'initiative d'emmanuel
macron c'est avec le tiroir cache dans
ton grâce à ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la nouvelle idée d' emmanuel
macron pour aider le continent africain
après avoir reçu les dirigeants
africains à paris en est déjà formulé
des inquiétudes quant à la lutte contre
l'occident en afrique
début juin à quelques jours des sommets
du g7 et de l'otan le président français
a exhorté le fmi à vendre une partie de
ses réserves d'or pour leur venir en
aide
l'idée serait en fait de financer un new
deal un grand plan de sauvetage à
hauteur de 100 milliards de dollars
car pour le moment les aides allouées
par le fmi à l'afrique ont été minimes
et s'élever à à peine 37 milliards de
dollars
avec également un gel de la tête dans
ces pays l'or valeur refuge par
excellence pourrait donc aider l'afrique
à se relever le fmi détient 2814 tonnes
d'or soit 192 milliards de dollars juste
derrière les états unis et l'allemagne
en france se sont donné 4 136 tonnes
d'or qui était conservée par la banque
de france
à la fin de l'année 2020 un peu plus de
120 milliards d'euros
reste à savoir si c'est le bon moment
pour vendre de l'or et si justement dans
un moment de crise et avec autant
d'argent qui circule sur les marchés en
ce moment il ne serait pas plus malins
même pour le fmi de garder ses réserves
de métal jaune vient justement donc avec
les liquidités en circulation en ce
moment est ce raisonnable que le fmi
vende ses réserves d'or maintenant mais
non comme d'habitude cet idiot c'est là
c'est un niveau
incompréhensible quand vous avez
justement les toutes les banques
centrales qui imprime à tour de bras
l'argent on sait que ça va forcément
diminuer la valeur des monnaies fiat est
donc forcément il est intéressant
d'avoir de l'or puisque c'est la
meilleure le meilleur refuge contre
contre l'inflation donc vraiment cc1 un
timing
kiki est à contretemps total et en plus
vous avez l'ensemble des banques
centrales surtout la banque centrale
chinoise et la banque centrale russe en
particulier qui achètent à tour de bras
la banque centrale indienne aussi qu'ils
achètent à tour de bras de l'or on pense
que onze on l'a dit plusieurs fois que
la chine essayer de rebaptiser sa
monnaie sur l'or et le rendre
convertible
ils ont fait des essais à petite échelle
mais on pense que ils vont le faire à
plus grande échelle au niveau asiatiques
et de toute la zone asie donc aller
vendre de l'or maintenant c'est ridicule
merci olivier tout de suite la deuxième
partie de cette émission et cette
semaine nous sommes en liaison avec jean
françois faure bonjour monsieur vous
êtes fondateur de aucoffre.com une
plateforme d'achat et de vente d'or
bienvenue dans ces caches merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci alors
jean-françois fort on l'a vu en première
partie en les filets pays africains ont
besoin de financer leur relance le
sommet qui s'est tenu en mai dernier a
confirmé l'émission de dts droits de
tirage spéciaux à hauteur de 33
milliards pour l'afrique mais emmanuel
macron souhaite aller plus loin et
atteindre les 100 milliards de dts le
chef de l'état qui a aussi évoqué l'idée
un d'un accord on l'a dit pour vendre
une partie des réserves d'or du fmi' en
écoute le chef de l'état c'était le 10
juin dernier le rendez-vous du g7 doit
permettre d'obtenir cet accord
historique avec comme objectif d'avoir
au moins 100 milliards de droits de
tirage spéciaux qui vont vers l'afrique
c'est un début essentiel ce mécanisme
devrait être complétée par un accord
pour vendre aussi une partie de nos
réserves d'or et financer ses
investissements
pourquoi parce que les réserves d'or du
fmi ont augmenté en valeur au bénéfice
de la crise parce que l'heure a été une
valeur refuge
utilisons ce surprofits pour justement
le donner aux pays les plus pauvres en
particulier africains qui en ont
aujourd'hui besoin
pas dans vingt ou trente ans aujourd'hui
jean-françois fort quand emmanuel macron
à lance cet appel on est d'accord qu'il
parle bien des réserves du fmi et non
des réserves indépendante des pays comme
on a pu le voir par exemple sur certains
sites oui tout à fait alors là il faut
quand même remettre en perspective on ne
parle pas d'une opération telle que
celle qui avait été opéré par nicolas
sarkozy en 2004 qui était clairement de
revendre une partie des réserves d'or de
la france ou d'autres pays qui
aujourd'hui possède des réserves donc là
c'est clairement lors du fmi qui est un
petit peu cette forme de pot commun dans
laquelle un peu de tout le monde amis et
je lui ai parlé je de remboursement de
dettes en grande partie aussi des pays
qui aujourd'hui peuvent être conseils
pour certains comme surendettées donc
c'est quand même un stock d'or qui n'a
pas été que constitué par les pays un
tri mais considérée comme riche mais
aussi par par tous les autres donc que
quelque part dans cette logique
lieven en renvoyer en finançant du
vaccin et pourquoi pas sur le sur le
principe
après la problématique c'est peut-être
d'employer le bon langage parce que
quand il parle de survaleur la valeur
sûre lors on ne peut l'acte et que quand
on revend une fois que l'on a vendu par
définition l'or ne se vend qu'une fois
et donc il devrait être en posture
ensuite de reconstituer des stocks si
vous voulez revenir sur le le stock
d'avant donc
donc là et pour rejoindre ce que disait
olivier l'or est un petit peu cet actif
ultime que l'on ne justement qu'on ne va
en qu'une fois pour régler un problème
qui lui se veut ponctuel mais régler un
problème durable par de la revente d'or
ça veut dire entraînée par la suite
d'autres mécanismes qui ne seront pas
nécessairement très bon et je pense que
de toute manière c'est thor ne serait
pas revendu il servirait certainement
d'actifs triple à qu'il est de toute
manière aujourd'hui les banques
reconnaissent les banques
internationales reconnaissent lors comme
actif triple a qui est pris pour sa
valeur donc si les prix aujourd'hui à sa
valeur de cours donc environ en euros
1500 euros on se retrouve effectivement
avec le millier de tonnes que possède le
fmi avec un potentiel de crédit auprès
de banques internationales qui pourrait
être très intéressant est donc cet or
resterait très probablement dans les
coffres oui je trouve aujourd'hui on va
on va développer ce point ainsi pas très
juste on première partie olivier évoqué
un mauvais timing est une décision à
contretemps est ce que c'est votre avis
aussi
alors tout dépend qu'est ce que l'on
considère comme bon timing est ce que
c'est un timing par rapport à la
nécessité d'agir
ou est ce que c'est un timing par
rapport à la valeur de l'or
certains disent que la valeur de l'or
pourrait être à dix mille dollars
d'autres pensent qu'on a atteint notre
maximum donc la valeur de l'or personne
n'est capable de la connaître dans le
futur on sait juste que c'est la
réconciliation entre des gens qui sont
capables de l'extraire et des gens qui
l'achètent et ceux qui achètent c'est
globalement les gens en inde pour
s'offrir des bijoux et donc aujourd'hui
la valeur de l'or est à peu près à un
sujet hors d'équilibré
donc si c'est par rapport à la valeur de
l'or on n'est pas nécessairement dans un
mauvais moment
ensuite si on considère que cet or pour
être utilisé dans des périodes beaucoup
plus grave que le monde dans lequel on
se trouve aujourd'hui un monde dans
lequel oui il faut financer probablement
des vaccins dans les pays qui ne peuvent
pas s'en doter pour bas demeurent très
pragmatique éviter que ces pays ensuite
nous nous contamine tous parce que c'est
finalement la vision des pays du g7
alors ce qu'ils ont fait leur sommet
peut-être que là il ya un mode de
financement peut être différent qui sera
à trouver et potentiellement gare dès
lors pour des moments beaucoup plus
compliqué et ce serait là où je
rejoindrai olivier sur peut-être mauvais
timing pour vendre les bijoux de la
reine
olivier le fmi on l'a dit à détient
environ 2800 14 tonnes d'or c'est la
troisième réserve d'or mondiale derrière
les états unis et l'allemagne alors qu
elle est concrète si on n'utilise pas
cet or pour en temps de pandémie quelle
est concrètement l'utilité plein
principal de cette réserve d'or du fmi
c'est une réserve c'est une garantie
d'une garantie qui peut être en effet
utilisé pour comme effet de levier si
vous voulez pour emprunter de l'argent
avec comme garantie cet or le problème
c'est que il est multiple fois en fait
garant de nombreux prêts que donc il ya
un souci c'est à dire qu'entre leur
physique et leur papier vous savez qu'il
ya 311 d'or papier pour une en or
physique donc ça veut dire qu'on a
multiplié multiplié les prêts avec
toujours la même garantie mais qu'est ce
que ça vaut puisque ça a été ça et ça a
servi de
levier et de levier dans des proportions
ahurissantes donc non sur le sur le
timing
en fait lors c'est quoi c'est c'est pas
un investissement c'est une assurance
bon donc c'est jamais bon d'être sans
assurance quoi qu'il arrive puisque le
jour ça ne servira que le jour où vous
aurez besoin c'est à dire le jour où il
y aura le feu dans la maison
ça veut dire que par exemple de
débloquer ces réserves ça nécessiterait
une crise une crise encore plus grave
mais non mais c'est que on est dans une
crise qui n'en finit pas puisque depuis
2009 les banques centrales n'ont qu'une
réponse à apporter
c'est l'impression monétaire donc on
sait que de toute façon la monnaie est
amené à se dévaluer gravement dans dans
l'est dans l'émoi dans les années qui
viennent puisqu'il n'y a pas de retour
en arrière possible
on vous l'a déjà dit plusieurs fois ici
les banques centrales ne peuvent pas
arrêter aujourd'hui d'un prix mais elles
continueront à un prix mais ça veut dire
que vous continuerez à avoir une
dépréciation de votre de vaud devises
donc la seule garantie aujourd'hui la
seule assurance peut vous avez c'est
justement lors alors y'a pas que l'or il
ya le patine il ya d'autres métaux mais
l'or et en est le principal acteur et
aujourd'hui vous permet d'aller vous
réfugier pour éviter cette dépréciation
monétaire
donc c'est pour ça que je dis que le
timing était affreusement mauvais parce
que on sait que ça va durer on sait que
la planche à billets va continuer et
donc mécaniquement
vous avez de plus en plus besoin d'avoir
des réserves en or
donc c'est idiot voilà après on peut
revenir sur la l'autre partie du
problème qui est le financement de
l'infrastructure ou autre en afrique
vous rappelle que ça fait des années
qu'on fait ça sauf qu'on prend le
problème exactement on traite le
problème comme on le traite en occident
on se dit que si on fait des investis
issement si l'état fait des
investissements ça va relancer la
croissance par de la dette en général
donc c'est idiot on sait ça marche pas
mais on continue et en fait qu'est ce
qu'on fait on regarde ce qui s'est passé
en afrique depuis des années qui prend
l'argent c'est les gouvernements
africains c'est pas le peuple africain
le peuple africain il reste toujours
aussi pauvre depuis des années donc tout
ça c'est pour engraisser quelques-uns
qui sont à la tête de certains états
complètement corrompu et qui vont
prendre les milliards on va leur offrir
et qui vont partir directement dans des
banques suisses
alors on va revenir sur ses propos
olivier ce sera juste après la pub
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine la
proposition à des manuels macron à de
débloquer les réserves d'or du fmi pour
venir en aide à l'afrique et pour en
parler nous sommes en liaison avec
jean-françois à fort fondateur de
aucoffre.com alors jean-françois forme
enfin juste avant la pub olivier évoqué
des soucis de corruption en cas
justement de déblocage de ses réserves
d'or comment est-ce que ça se passe
concrètement mais la description
d'olivier effectivement juste si on se
retrouve un signé un chèque auprès de
ses différents et en est malheureusement
personne dans la population n'aura
l'effet de ce pour quoi ils ont reçu un
financement
donc ce genre de deux mécanismes qui se
montrait d'une manière efficace donc cet
or on part du principe même s'il a déjà
été louée 30 fois et qu'en fait il
appartient déjà à des fonds de tf on est
bien on est tous bien d'accord mais on
n'est pas un deuxième ou troisième
levier
ils sont pas à ça près l'idée c'est
effectivement des airs de de dégager un
financement sous forme d'une nouvelle
d'une nouvelle dette de pouvoir signer
un chèque à au laboratoire qui au final
eux seraient les seuls à délivrer les
vaccins directement dans les pays et
cela de manière gratuite pour éviter
qu'ils en plus un marché noir qui se
crée autour des vaccins parce qu'à ce
moment là les vaccins deviendrait humain
même une monnaie une monnaie d'échangé
dans ce genre de pays
vous seriez habilité à la voir en
moyennant finance donc et c'est ce que
l'on a vu un de mer très fréquentes
lorsqu'il y avait des crises sanitaires
où je pars à des tremblements de terre
et c'est souvent une partie des fois des
fonds étaient détournés et ensuite les
sacs de blé revendus voilà donc c'est là
où les ong auraient leur rôle à jouer
bon an mal an pour arriver à ce que cela
puisse aller à la bonne destination
moi ce que je joue les noter par contre
c'est que dans ce discours du président
mais je pense qu' évidemment il n'a pas
fait exprès mais d'une certaine manière
il a verbalement re monétiser leurs mais
en fait bon l'or était déjà une forme de
monnaie complémentaire universel puisque
aujourd'hui de nombreuses achats
commerciaux entre certains pays qui ne
veulent qui veulent s'affranchir du
dollar ils ne veulent pas être tracées
dans d'autres monnaies utilisent l'or
alors certains pour financer leur
pétrole d'autres pour financer peut-être
des moyens de se défendre de gros pays
voisins qui pourraient leur faire du mal
et c'est donc aujourd'hui l'or est une
monnaie universelle
et sur le coup le président macron bain
en rappelant que ça pouvait être ce
genre d'actifs utilisable et mobilisable
à tout instant à redonner un caractère
monétaire alors bon évidemment moi j'ai
trouvé ça fort intéressant mais on sait
très bien que ce n'est pas le cas pour
preuve tous les travaux aujourd'hui
menée par nos banques centrales pour
créer des euro numérique le 8 juin et
c'est qu'ils sont en train de tout cas
le yin qui va petit à petit prendre une
place prépondérante par rapport à toutes
les autres monnaies direction alors
attention jean-françois parce que dans
la dans les propositions de monsieur
macron s'était pas juste pour payer les
vaccins les secours ce qui voulait faire
c'était pour financer des plans de
relance par l'investissement en
infrastructures etc
le problème de l'afrique c'est pas des
investissements en infrastructures qu'il
acquit qui a posé problème c'est que ce
sont eux on a vendu l'afrique
maintenant c'est là c'est la chine qui
la détient avant c'était la france qui
la détenaient et qu'est ce qu'on faisait
on retirait des ressources du continent
africain on les emmenait à l'extérieur
du continent africain et on les
transforme et or la valeur ajoutée elle
est où elle est sur la transformation
elle n'est pas sur l'extraction de la
matière première donc
résultat ils ne voyaient pas la valeur
ajoutée passé or aujourd'hui le
principal problème c'est ça c'est de
leur permettre eu de s'industrialiser
pour pouvoir remettre de la valeur
ajoutée et la garder la valeur ajoutée
tant qu'ils ne la garderons pas vous
aurez une afrique qui sera un désert
économique comme il l'a été depuis
depuis 30 ans donc c'est pas des
infrastructures qu'il faut qu'il faut
acheter
c'est pas non plus des palais
présidentiel qu'il faut financer
c'est simplement le fait eux ils
puissent s'industrialiser ils puissent
garder donc la valeur ajoutée sur leur
sol et non pas la voir partir
systématiquement en europe ou en
occident
juste en fait d'un point juste et ce sur
quoi il faut vraiment appuyé c'est aussi
cette course contre la montre vis-à-vis
de la chine puisque comme tu le signal
est aujourd'hui les infrastructures
neuf qui se construisent en afrique sont
essentiellement des infrastructures
chinoises et aujourd'hui la france on
l'aura tous noté n'est plus un pays en
mode colonisation de ses voisins et en
tout état de cause n'a pas les moyens de
rentrer dans ce genre de mode est donc
quelque part le fmi est un biais pour
faire financer quelque part par les
autres parce que finalement c'est une
cagnotte qu'on peut imaginer détenus par
les autres pour financer quelque chose
que la france ne peut plus ou ne veut
plus financer pour au plein de raisons
dont quelque part c'est laisser la dette
aux autres dom plan stratégique qui lui
sur le court est assez français ou en
tout cas européen
et comme par hasard c'est le président
macron le président de la france qui
propose cette idée donc voilà en ligne
de mire on a can la chine en jean
françois forestier a déjà eu des
précédents est ce que le fmi a déjà
débloqué ses réserves pour venir en aide
à un pays ou un continent où est ce que
c'est une première non mais les réserves
à prendre par les réserves à proprement
parler ne sont jamais débloqué ils ne
sont jamais débloqué et finalement le ce
que la sq a pu évoquer le président mc
ren macro ne se passera pas de manière
directe à mon sens aucun gramme d'or ne
sera vendu
par contre comme on le décrivait tout à
l'heure avec olivier ses kilos c'est
tonnes d'or seront à nouveau nantis
comme couverture par rapport à de
nouveaux crédits qui seront émis pour
financer ces différents projets et on va
rentrer dans un phénomène qui est assez
classique et plutôt que cet or soit mis
à disposition de tels fonds edf se sera
mis à disposition d'une banque
internationale qui arrivera même au
passage à gagner quelques subsides pour
mettre en place tout cela olivier leur
est il amené à rester une valeur refuge
était en allemand bah écoutez le
l'éternel est difficile à prévoir par
définition donc je me risquerai pas à ça
mais oui on va en tout cas ça fait quand
même des centaines d'années et qui
quelle qu'elles sont et une
et je vous dis avec l'action des banques
centrales
tant qu'on n'aura pas réformer le
système monétaire est profondément
réformer le système monétaire dans le
monde
eh bien je pense que l'or va continuer à
être une valeur refuge et à être une
nation je vous dis touriste est le
principal risque aujourd'hui ces deux
d'avoir en fait sur toutes les monnaies
ce qu'est aujourd'hui si vous voulez le
venezuela ou ska et et l'argentine c'est
à dire tout d'un coup une inflation de 6
mille pour cent et un billet qui ne vaut
plus rien sur lequel on rajoute des
zéros tous les jours pour pour se payer
aujourd'hui il faut plusieurs millions
de bolivars pour se payer un kilo de
viande donc voilà et on en est là alors
que et ne croyez pas que c'est
simplement parce que c'est le venezuela
le problème c'est que si vous avez une
une banque centrale qui n'arrêtent pas
d'émettre des billets nouveau et bien le
gâteau lui ne se ne s'élargit pas ne
grossit pas et vous le dit viser sans
arrêt en part de plus en plus petit
jusqu'à ce que ça arrive à la miette et
c'est ce qui est arrivé je vous dis au
venezuela ou en argentine
et c'est ce qui arrivera de toute façon
à tous les pays qui utilisent ce procédé
alors évidemment comme sont des pays qui
sont plus importants avec une base plus
importante
ça met plus de temps c'est tout mais de
toute façon la conclusion sera la même
un ben stein disait que seuls les fous
pense que la même action peu
aboutir à des résultats différents donc
vous n'aurez pas un résultat différent
ça mettra un petit peu plus de temps
mais vous n'aurez pas un résultat
différent
jean gross à faire une dernière réaction
de ceux qui s'est tant qu'on n'aura pas
réformer le système monétaire l'or
restera une assurance vous êtes d'accord
ça c'est une évidence puisqu'il à cette
posture d'entre eux deux donc
effectivement une assurance incendie
du reste de son patrimoine canadien
particuliers ou du reste de ses dettes
quand on est un état d'un côté cette
assurance et de l'autre côté cette quasi
monnaie que certains sont prêts à
réactiver comme comme tel c'est déjà le
cas dans certains pays alors d'autres
ont franchi un cap beaucoup plus loin
puisqu'ils ont carrément maintenant
utiliser les crypto monnaie comme comme
valeur légale dans leur pays mais lors
la différence d'une crypto c'est que
globalement si vous coupez le courant ça
fonctionne quand même encore
et pour preuve c'est une monnaie
justement qui est utilisé par des fois
de manière un petit peu parallèle dans
certains pays qu'on a plus rien d'autre
donc voilà l'or
fait partie de ces actifs qui ne
disparaissent jamais vraiment et en
collant à cet équilibre un petit peu
magique entre ceux qui savent le
produire le recycler et ceux qui de
l'autre côté l'achète pour le coup des
raisons qui sont entrés mais beaucoup
plus belle puisque finances et de
l'amour et c'est les bijoux qu'on peut
offrir puisque c'est ça qui est le coeur
du marché de l'or et c'est ce qui crée
sa valeur au quotidien en dehors des
crises et bien voilà cet équilibre
magique fait que l'or ne va pas quitter
la scène de suite et y compris pour des
problématiques monétaire ou pour couvrir
les dettes que l'on ne voudrait pas
qu'on ne voudrait pas voir couvrir par
nos enfants merci beaucoup jean-françois
fort d'avoir été à parmi nos je rappelle
que vous êtes le fondateur de
aucoffre.com une plateforme d'achat et
de vente d'un vivier merci à vous c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant rendez vous sur
notre site internet air france point tv
pour découvrir toutes vos précédentes
émissions et on se quitte avec vous faut
lier leurs un jour lors toujours